give her a kiss really sure yeah come on
give me a kiss big boy hey what's up not
too loose uh it is time to make another
episode of checkmate Lincoln ads are
wildly unpopular internet show no it man
no I am done talking about the Civil War
oh come on now so everybody wants you to
do it I don't care I used to think that
my Civil War videos can do some good you
know but nobody's minds are getting
changed or the second coming of hippy
Jesus you know there are some people out
there who called me a bread tuber bread
tuba does that refer to vino farms early
content no apparently it's just liberals
who make youtube videos well that's the
silliest thing I've ever heard I know
I'm just so over it well that's no fun
for anybody just let me make my weird
homoerotic Nazi videos in peace Jesus
I'm sorry you feel that way sigh I
suppose I'll have to do it myself and I
can tell everyone how the War of
Northern Aggression was fought over
tariffs and taxes
I'm on my way
[Music]
what you got there oh it's just a
delicious bottle of Jack Daniels I'm
playing the what about ism drinking game
basically whenever you try to divert the
conversation by pointing out something
bad the union did I take a drink that's
ridiculous
you Yankees do that just as much as we
do checkmate link enacts the program
where we are now late academic
historical consensus in favor of true
history which my grandpapa revealed to
me one Lee Jackson day after he had
consumed an entire 12-pack and a delight
all by herself tonight we shall revealed
the truth reason for southern secession
preserving slavery yeah civil war was
fought over slavery not the South was
paying 80% of the taxes of the entire
nation what cat got your tongue can't
think I wanna y'all Pythia comebacks no
I'm I'm just trying to process what you
just said so that's not true it's not
even close to truth it's not enough 50
mile radius of truth like if you dropped
an atomic bomb on truth what you just
said wouldn't even have radiation burns
see in the days before the civil war
income taxes property taxes sales taxes
those weren't really a thing so when
you're saying taxes you're referring to
tariffs on imports which is how the
federal government made its money we
actually have a record of most of the
foreign goods imported into the United
States just before the war and the
annual report of the Chamber of Commerce
of the state of New York the report
shows that from July 1859 to June 1860
two hundred and thirty three point seven
million dollars worth of foreign goods
were brought into the port of New York
of which 203 point four million were
subject to tariffs during that same time
period all other American ports combined
took in just one hundred twenty-eight
point five million dollars worth of
goods of which seventy six point five
million were subject to tariffs the
numbers don't lie New York merchants
were single handedly paying
63.5% of all the federal government's
revenue that year and it wasn't just
some anomaly New York had provided
nearly two thirds of the government's
revenue in the previous five years as
well that city was the government's
biggest cash cow by a huge margin
followed only distantly by Boston and
second place and New Orleans and third
hey hey did you listen to a word I just
said
the south left because of the Marlin
10th the Union guilty men's and exiled
Jews look up Judah P Benjamin the Jewish
Confederation but why did the Federals
fact the Yankee mercantilism that was
gonna be in trouble if the south won its
independence oh no they will have a next
door competitor charging a ten percent
tariff compared to the Morrill tariff of
40 percent there you go checkmate
Lincoln ass that's the name of the
program you want to talk about the moral
tariff let's talk about the moral tariff
put very simply it was a reaction to the
panic of 1857 and it was meant to
jumpstart the nation's struggling
economy it may have aided yo Hamiltonian
industries but not our Jeffersonian
agriculture yeah we're just trying to
develop your New England factories into
something that would rival the
profitable and we'll established
factories of Britain meanwhile you had
Pennsylvania n--'s in particular but men
in northern industrialists petitioning
the government to make it more favorable
for them financially beneficial for them
the whole affair reach the nepotism and
corruption furthermore all right I am
yes that is what happened
wait we actually agree on something yes
the Morrill tariff was unquestionably
favorable for northern interests and
detrimental to southern ones but it
wasn't passed through Congress until
March of 1861 and if southern states had
started seceding in December of 1860 and
there's no [__] way it would have
gotten passed so rather than being the
cause of secession the Morrill tariff
happened as a result of secession in any
case it was just one of many grievances
that Southern Democrats had with
northern Republicans the
one was the Republican stance on slavery
saying the civil war was only about
slavery is ignant the civil war was
extremely complicated what about the
tariff of 1816 why literally all the
dozens of newspapers speaking of a tax
war most historians agree that the Civil
War was too complicated to tear what
about the 70% a man who didn't own
slaves and fought for what well at least
you got the percentage of slave owners
right this time those newspapers you're
referring to were mainly British rags
like the London Times
the Brits they had a vested interest in
keeping that transatlantic cotton trade
going to fuel their own industries
naturally they sided with the southern
democrats who were all about free trade
and they shared their criticisms of the
moral tariff which was extremely
protective the confederate government
desperately needed british assistance
that they had any hope of winning the
war so they encouraged that myth that
the war was being fought over taxes
Britain of course being very
anti-slavery at the time but some
British abolitionists knew better the
philosopher John Stuart Mill wrote an
opinion piece in a pro-union newspaper
in 1862 in which he correctly stated
there is a theory in England but on the
side of the North the question is not
one of slavery at all the north it seems
I have no more objection to slavery than
the South have their leaders never say
one word implying disapprobation of it
they are ready on the contrary to give
it new guarantees to renounce or what
they have been contending for to win
back if opportunity offers the south to
the Union by surrendering the hill point
if this be the true state of the case
what other southern chiefs fighting
about their apologists in England to say
that it is about tariffs and similar
trumpery they say nothing of the kind
they tell the world and they told their
own citizens when they wanted their
votes that the object of the fight was
slavery the world knows with the
question between the North and South has
been for many years and still it's
slavery alone was thought up alone
talked of slavery was battled for and
against on the floor of Congress and in
the plains of Kansas on the slavery
question exclusively was the party
constituted which now rules the United
States on slavery Fremont was rejected
on slavery Lincoln was elected the silt
separated on slavery and proclaimed
slavery as the one cause of separation
he goes on to predict that as the war
continued the cause of preserving the
Union would become inseparable from the
cause of abolishing slavery that came to
pass when Lincoln signed the
Emancipation Proclamation after that as
a direct result of that the British
public became very uncomfortable with
the idea of supporting the Confederacy
in your eagerness to blame white people
in every video you make you forgotten
about the Nullification Crisis south
carolina nearly rebelled during Andrew
Jackson's presidency over just such a
protectionist tariffs that's true but as
Johnson Calhoun himself pointed out in
1830 I can say that the tariff act of
the occasion rather than the real cause
of the present on happy state of thing
the truth can no longer be disguised at
the peculiar domestic institution of the
southern states and the consequent
direction which they and her soil has
given to our industry has placed them in
regard to taxation and appropriations in
opposite relation to the majority of a
million
so in summary protective tariffs were a
big point of contention between north
and south leading up to the Civil War
but it was ancillary to and directly
influenced by the South's dependency on
slave labor which they would do anything
to preserve and defend you can eat [__]
if the North was so damn noble why did
the same damned army that invaded the
South kill the American Indians sounds
like [__] to me bad debate with a
real person instead of playing with your
city stop whining because we have had so
much pro-union one side and crap you get
triggered when the tagger side is
allowed to have their say the south us
everywhere south of the Canadian border
both were pro-slavery the Confederacy
jurors never lied about now I'm gonna
bring some Confederate flag waving get
popped up in black and dance' 'play by
the comic Tubbs create the ultimate
dilemma meaningful connection with human
beings
[__] we enjoy hit play outside or some
[__] that mama see you later belay I
feel like that went well
[Music]
Oh